[Music]
every once in a while a movie comes
along that is of its time and it is a
moment in time it is a moment in history
i imagine wizard of oz was like that for
our parents generation or back to the
future back to the future for for me
yeah and um for the generation behind us
it was it happened in 1997 a little
movie called titanic
don't you think titanic's been described
more in that way than in like a
blockbuster movie no i don't oh really
no yeah okay oh yeah it's just my
opinion man you could be right well
because people are always like yeah
little indie like maybe it's just people
i know maybe it's just people or me
maybe it's just me
um
anyway uh it was it captivated a nation
and
i remember being a freshman at a cool
college progressive liberal arts college
you know i was getting into like indie
art cinema and kind of pretentious
movies and so the fact that that movie
was so popular was really a deterrent
for me at the time so i i didn't see it
at when it came out i didn't see it even
for the first couple of months uh when
it was out and i only saw it
like i must have been six seven months
later it was out for so long had a
second run theater in poughkeepsie and
um i begrudgingly went i thought well i
should see this eventually i should see
it on the big screen it's james cameron
and uh i was almost immediately
captivated and i i was glad it was i saw
it when i did because there was nobody
around me and it was during a time in my
life where i thought it was a little bit
um
uncool to show my emotions
and now i love it i'm doing it all the
time so what's the lesson of this story
what's the moral um you should just go
along with the crowd
there's a reason things are so popular
sometimes it's true yeah popular for a
reason right and in this case it's a
an incredible i mean i don't have to
tell anyone it's an incredible speaking
of popular
our yes the show let's do it let's do it
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
you're listening to life is short
i am your host justin long life could be
a dream sweetheart
[Music]
and with me as always is um
christian long co-host i was younger
when that movie came out obviously
because i'm younger than you
i was in high school
and i remember i also didn't see it
right away because i was you know both
of you would not have seen titanic right
when it came out because you thought oh
you were too cool it was not cause i was
too cool i was just like overwhelmed by
the height it wasn't cool to like be
that into like super popular things i
guess so i don't know if it was so
mainstream maybe i don't remember
thinking like i'm gonna be cool and not
see this no i know i just remember being
like sick of it based on how much people
were talking about it and like the
commercials and that celine dion song i
was like and leo being like like poster
boy he was like such an idol he was such
a like well that i was gonna say that i
remember because even though i hadn't
seen the movie i i was like swept up in
leo mania and i remember wait you
personally no but it was my school i was
15 16 years old but you weren't stricken
with leo mania i wasn't because i hadn't
i mean i loved basketball diaries
no i really liked him as an actor but
when titanic came out he became like
he was a guy on every girl's wall he was
on yeah poster of leo on everyone's wall
and everyone talked about him and i
remember thinking this is really bad for
boys
in my generation because
girls liked him so much that
comparatively we were like lepers oh my
god because he was so not only obviously
so good-looking but charming and and
impressive and he must
when he walks around in the world it
must be so
wild to be him and and women of i mean
all generations i think he crossed
you know he brought he he was like a
universally beloved
idol he still is still is why are we
talking about leo and right specifically
titanic well i'll tell you why really
good pivot uh because our guest today
played the villain in titanic
he is um and and he himself is not at
all villainous he actually
come to find out is a very charming guy
like leo very handsome very very
charming in his own right yes despite
his bad guy persona in that movie yes
that was your microphone it was yeah
ding oh yeah my fingers hit it all right
our guest today also has fingers
his name is billy zane
our guest our very special guest uh he's
been in other
i i almost said erotic movies um iconic
movies he has been in a robotic movie
he's been in iconic movies and erotic
movies
um ironic movies yeah yeah like mcgruber
right now uh he's in our favorite new
comedy uh mcgruber which is out on
peacock
it is
the best it's one of the funniest things
i've seen in a long time we talk all
about it but he's also in uh who does he
play in magruber
he plays oh that's such a great name
queefed
he plays a guy named queef venus queef
um and he's kind of like taking over for
the role that val kilmer played in the
movie which was uh colonel uh kunth yes
and um
it is just the best uh if you like the
movie and if you liked if you like those
names and you find you find those them
funny if you're rolling you're if you're
a mother and you're rolling your eyes
yeah maybe you don't see it but if you
do think that's funny then you'll
definitely like macgruber oh yeah and um
billy's been in he's also in my favorite
movie i was speaking of iconic uh movies
he was in back to the future he was in
biff's gang yeah and uh the sequel yes
and too uh so there's obviously
zoolander one and two oh man
also iconic and his erotic work you
might not know he was in a lot of like
salman k i think he was in those like
early 2000s movies yes movies that um
you know i
i enjoyed when i was a younger man and
um but he's he's always does great work
uh and i was obviously excited to talk
to him because he had never met him no i
had not met billy um and so i didn't
know what to expect you know he's
somebody who's been in pop culture so
long i've obviously been aware of him
since i was little and um he's been
used in pop culture in different ways
like he's been used in ironic ways yeah
he has a he has a really interesting
reputation in the zeitgeist yeah he does
um and kind of eccentric yes and we get
into some of that i didn't really
realize how eccentric um
we talk about his art and reminds me a
little bit of
the the place that crispin glover
occupies
in our uh in our pop culture it's a good
comparison yeah so again somebody oh god
it would be great to have him on the
show but it's also great to have billy
on the show so why don't we get into the
show yes with billy on it let's do it
here he is um
the uh iconic and uh erotic and uh
ironic
and very talented billy zane
life could be a dream
[Music]
billy why do you have so many glasses
available
because i'm blind
no no no but like they're within reach
they're all i'm usually i have a a
veritable runway of options
i brought a few i thought oh this will
go with my jacket
you do look great i truly look great
it's um it's amazing because i've been
seeing you for so long and you still
you you must be sick of hearing this
people must say this to you all the time
you look the same i mean you look like
you have you you know you never change
you you were you know
you're stuck in your tweet you look like
you're 20. you're always like you're 20.
well well thanks a lot billy um it's
true billy thank you for doing this
because i uh there's so many things to
talk about the first thing though is
that i i truly i've been watching you
since i was a kid and this is a thrill
for me to get to to talk to you and nerd
out on you a little bit
thank you the feeling is mutual not
since i was a child of course but i've
been i've been a great fan of your work
you know thanks billy no you're in
you're incredibly funny but um always
sincere and really grounded and in the
moment and you're very you're you're a
great actor you seem as
kind and approachable in your work as
you are that i've gathered in the five
minutes that we've spent well that's
that's all the time we have so thank you
yeah another one i tricked you uh thank
you for saying that i appreciate i hope
um this this lives up to that um the
feeling that you have uh
the first thing i saw you and i i didn't
realize it was your first movie i didn't
know back to the future was the first
screen roll for you
baptism by far
how did that come about and did you have
any idea that it would become what it
became
no other than
you know you knew you were working for
universal and yeah gambling and
spielberg and you're going well you know
bt right just
jaws certainly um i you knew you were
working with arguably the best at that
time but i was 18. wow i was just off
the boat i was you know in town from
chicago from chicago wow wow so it was
it was a great gift to
[Music]
um
two weeks have that be a point of entree
into hollywood it certainly set the bar
ridiculous yeah yeah i'll say
and i was like you mean they're all not
yeah i know i it wasn't back to the
future but i had a similarly high bar
set my first thing was galaxy quest and
same thing i had never been to la i mean
it was all so new to me but um and
people say well you know how did that
come up but people ask a similar thing
and i tell them what what the same thing
you you would probably say which is i
would have done anything at the time i
would have done it just so happened
that was the thing that with that cast i
mean what a great
introduction i mean my god just luck you
know so so you're there for two weeks
do you go with the purpose of i mean
obviously you wanted to be an actor you
were looking for acting work but but was
it just as simple as i got an audition
and i went in and read it was it fenton
mike fenton um it was and it was an
audition i had i was fortunate enough to
have a an agent
um affiliate in chicago when i first i
guess i was
auditioning for things there when i was
you know
16.
okay this was the beginning of the kind
of teen
yes market the 80s teen scene the john
hughes universe was just happening
and john shot a lot in chicago right you
did yeah it's from there so there was um
but they were casting
always you know out of la as well as
chicago yeah yeah the idea was to go
i wanted to go to film school i i was
enamored by what was happening behind
camera although i had acted quite a bit
in school play and
and very entrained
in it
knowing that that was the point of
entree that a young man would probably
find
fortune and success
you know that's why you were doing
theater so you had your site set on
something bigger in high school like
when you were doing school plays
it was my
um
rationalization for you know mediocre
application on my part into your
scholastic future yeah it's like
no no no
well well it wasn't a total it wasn't
totally outside the realm of possibility
because you're first of all obviously
you're talented you're a good-looking
kid but also your parents i didn't know
this your parents were
amateur actors
well the term amateur is is a is a
wikipedia you know
kind of misfire that's not where i got
it that's not where i got it from i
don't know semi-pro i talked to that
mature actor you know it's it's it's
they were professionals
you know they were um paid for their
services
and they were and they were phenomenal
oh okay but i grew up watching them on
stage i guess yeah
page work amateur wikipedia my mom my
mom was also a stage actress and did
some commercials to to you know pay the
bills and stuff so i
i feel you and i and i do apologize
because that is it does have a
pejorative ring to it amateur
um and and now they were pro yeah and
grew up watching them on stage and
learned from them as i imagine you did
yeah um
but it was and they were very supportive
of the of the choice
again i was always fascinated by um
by filmmaking and
had made you know had worked for
um
richard shirley uh commercial director
in chicago and was pa oh wow doing you
know i i was trying to spend as much
time on any crew as i could just to
learn but i i realized quickly
you know the
the way you're going to work with
amazing people
under the circumstances was to lean into
the act yeah
it worked i found myself in this crazy
episode thus observing
you know that the first time a
motion control rig was being tested oh
wow you know
spielberg like that was what just like
fly on the wall yeah those crazy moments
where this new technology was was being
you know forged was fast and were you
allowed to do that were they
did they allow you to kind of hang
around the camera just to absorb yeah
yeah how cool they're very generous with
process i've been fortunate that many of
the directors i've worked with many of
the most celebrated were always very
inclusive yeah and generous was it a
close-knit group i know michael j fox
was
working on family ties at the time so he
wasn't as probably as as
around socially we would you guys hang
out i guess uh off game yeah jj cohen we
you know we would we'd play during the
filming
exploring universal backlot
on lunch break lunch was the most fun
totally yes i love that you know like
it's like having a it's jumping off the
tram for like you know six months yeah
and having the run of the joint yeah and
going and i would just love hanging out
in amityville and watch the shark attack
the tram might go to mexico where you
want to go to the gilligan's island
let's part the red sea should we part
the red sea today that's so fun the red
sea then it's so funny billy i did that
let's go up to psycho yes that's so
weird i i it's so weird so i was a kid
who was just i fell in love with the
movies because of that movie and and
and then a couple of years later i was
15 20 years old so i'm doing die hard at
that lot at the university and i i felt
the exact same thing i would go on the
tram and i would maggie q was in the
movie we would just jump we would just
run around that that backlot but i would
go but funny enough i would go you know
your attraction your movie was like the
attraction at the time and but i did the
same thing psycho and and jaws that big
uh plane crash isn't that that's funny
ah it's really surreal to me that you
would have that's wonderful and die hard
and their your reaction you made that
such a an entertaining journey
especially at this the time when they
made it there was such an you know
new state of the art uh effects yeah
yeah in you know improbability and the
magnitude of the things you had to react
to were really exciting and funny as
hell that that combination of your
reactions to what was happening to you
was
that's nice of you to say but also
interesting because you you had you were
experiencing a new technology on by the
future as were we i was going to say we
had a um an insert car that was a brand
new it was i think porsche made it and
they had just used it on one of the
bourne movies but they so we got to get
drag you know you do those scenes it's
usually like you're going 20 miles an
hour you know you're going pretty soon
and then you have to act like it's but
they were really dragging us real time
like i don't 60 70 it wasn't like 150
but it was it's a lot it was enough to
like you know like you said get to react
to so we got we got lucky um what what
was
so for you it was it just
it was it wide-eyed excite was it like
did you had your have your sights set on
something specific was it i want to be
uh a lead of a movie was it just i want
to be like my parents and do as much
theater was it about the work
my
folks were very generous in exposing me
to
great cinema as well as great theater
right we'd take trips to england to see
some of the best of the english stage as
well as watching chicago you know forage
it's
you know make its mark with steppenwolf
and that whole team all you know before
malkovich i think came out just before
cines you know came just before and they
were with my same agency um at the time
um
and they had i had seen them on stage in
chicago
it really did shape and set the bar in
terms of the caliber and work that was
that was kind of now expected yeah but
um i had been you know weaned on
you know mgm yeah and gene kelly and
john wayne and
carrie grant so i
wanted to be a movie star there was no
question that it was like yeah
bring chicago caliber acting but it was
all about being like don lockwood yeah
from singing in the raid you know yeah
so
i was very clear upon
the whimsy and the fun of the joy cinema
brings i was while i enjoyed hard-boiled
70s cop movies and you know the odd
gangster film or maybe
you know some of my peers were maybe
enamored by a little more serious
modern i was i was incredibly nostalgic
and sentimental that's interesting billy
because your work has always had a touch
of that there's a playfulness even when
you're playing these unsavory characters
there there's always a twinkle there's a
i specifically obviously titanic was a
huge one but there's a playful quality
to them and i'm that's on full display
in mcgruber which i can't wait to talk
about it's not it's weird because it's
not winking it's not you're not winking
at all it's committed but it's um
yeah there's a playfulness it's
interesting you say that did it surprise
you when your career did take that turn
because you're known
since titanic i'm sure people
approach you and say things like you
know i'm surprised you're just talking
to i'm surprised you're such a nice you
seem like such a nice person
no but it happened before i mean
curiously with boats i you know you i i
i did a film um
one of my favorites uh called dead calm
oh yeah
what a great director i love that yeah
brilliant show yeah and you know
and i i think i got the part because i
brought counterpoint or maybe a
surprising spin upon whatever
uh traumatized behavior yeah
yeah which became a foil um you know bad
guy at sea was kind of like my my thing
and uh yeah i came here to catch a pie
in the face and tap dance and you know
throw a punch and kiss the girl be a
white hat hero and i found myself you
know being basil rathbone you know yes
totally basil wrath well defend
the phantom was more errol flynn the
phantom was more there you go yeah well
that was that was the counterpoint that
i had pined for and
um
got i i had always loved that character
and i didn't collect a lot of comics
until the phantom when i was in
australia doing another film that was an
important turn for you because it was
what kind of what you had envisioned as
the high point of what an acting career
could be it was what you had always sort
of like a swashbuckling
uh
yeah yeah yeah there was elements of
vero flynn there was elements of tarzan
there was
clark kent there was you know he was a
well-adjusted hero and we leaned in on
the fact that there wasn't a lot of
baggage and he didn't have superpowers
which i loved he was it was actually
attainable
and written as such as a kind of a
fantasy projection of the male archetype
i think written for women to be honest
in a in a women's magazine in a cereal
and then it found itself into
newspaper newsprint
um it was this kind of projected
you know ideal
um
but i love the fact that he
he disarmed he wasn't you know he didn't
kill like
he existed before the
love of an anti-hero yes
which is still so pervasive and i think
you know
i like it as counterpoint but i just
think it's it's overkill so to speak
yeah yeah that's true well i mean
there's now it's now being parodied i
mean a lot of that stuff is being
parodied now and and uh those great
action movies are being parodied so well
and with macgruber i i really want to
talk about that in more detail but i was
curious curious were you a fan of the
original were you a fan of the movie
absolutely yeah yeah i i i
i'm such a fan to be a fan of the films
obviously to be the a fan of of
the talent uh behind it um
yarma and john crafted something so
beautiful but will is probably the most
the bravest actor yes
you know talk about commitment
so committed and so self-effacing and
what works so beautifully is is the
pathos and level of sincerity he brings
to the most absurd thing he can say the
most ridiculous things and he does the
craziest most shocking [ __ ] comes out of
his mouth
but he you you find yourself
howling with laughter because you're
you're so drawn into his commitment and
belief
so i though the bar when i saw it i was
like this is amazing and always was a
fan and they in the series this is not
they take it even further i mean like
he'll
commit to you know like the ball the
ball up the ass scene with the with the
with the inmate you know
are you getting that ball out of my ass
like it's it's almost like it's not
funny until they hit the joke too hard
yes it it third time yeah
or with wigs wig song in the in the
first episode oh my god so chris wake
has a song
forever first of all everyone has to see
this i'm sure everyone will see it but
it's um
it it's it's so absurd it goes on so
long that it's funny at first but then
the longer it's one of those rare things
that the longer it goes on the funnier
it gets you know
and it really touches upon a lot of
modern writing yeah which is like
shopping list writing you know
you know i brushed my teeth she did this
she's rhyming all this stuff yeah
rhyming terrible rhymes just goes on and
on and it it really is a uh
was a it
took to task i think a lot of
um
[Music]
yeah yeah the absurdity of a lot of
the self-indulgence mediocre yeah
mediocre self-important
[Music]
you play kind of the heavy the bad guy
but um
what how difficult was it then to commit
in that way to like
to play it straight
and then
have to not laugh when will says these
crazy things i mean it was it was it was
painful to you know
i as i said there's a whole movie that
exists before action and after cut yeah
and you know
that compiled would be very exciting and
to you know you mentioned ryan who i
have to say
was
i probably one of my favorite characters
in the piece because he's really the
audience he totally is the voice of
reason that's settled at the hip his
reactions are just so precious he's so
committed and grounded i know of course
it doesn't you know
it doesn't work if there's a wink
there's anything exactly exactly um he's
so sincere and he's brilliant yeah it's
just so so funny but i i i kept putting
myself in the in that in his shoes and
in your shoes and the hardest part as
good as you both are and as as different
as that your characters are
i i don't know that i'd be able to get
through those scenes without laughing
i'm
i i hate saying that i just don't that
requires a certain level of commitment
that i don't i don't think can be
overstated how how much
what what was your first
uh experience like with that were you
afraid to like was it that like
where are other people laughing how does
that work like who's the first to break
i'll put it this way i mean we having
been on comedies where
the character even the actor of course
is very in on the joke this is this was
a very unique uh experience
you know there's a lot of comedies that
rely on improvisation and a lot of
changes and you'll see them because they
often out themselves during the credits
you'll see outtakes of actors just
free-forming and what was hodge podge
together is a feature based on a lot of
crazy and loose improv
this is different because we stuck to
screen i bet the most part i bet with
you know it wasn't about let me you know
and the let me try as there were two or
three versions already
pretty much crafted to attempt again
this is a product of the writer's room
of an snl mindset so it has a different
kind of meticulous approach
so the the economy and the focus was
much more
acute than
than a
let's say a more free-form
feature that's taking a parody it seems
that way yeah it felt that way the thing
about will's work is he couldn't afford
to break yeah
because it would take him out of the
level of sincerity he was in so honoring
that you we we stayed in this in the
seriousness of the subject so it was
different than you would just you would
expect everyone's just turning to jello
every five seconds which does happen
right you can't there are times you
can't help it and personally it's just
every time i hear the word
or queef like
well i know i can imagine was that just
like a call that you get and you're like
oh thank god is that one of those calls
you get and you just think
you know this is one that you wait for
yeah yeah no no question yeah i i had
the pleasure of working with kristen and
zoolander too in rome oh yes
that group of people running amok you
know
you know amazing dinners funny
performances she's an incredible singer
as you guys yes learning the ukulele and
i think through a dinner for the whole
cast so she could play the four songs
she rehearsed and then did duets with a
few of us it was
such a generous spirit on set and off i
think kristen put in a good word and was
like you got to get billy uh
that's cool
well yeah you're sort of playing the
counterpoint to um to val kilmer's
character and again another like
great actor probably somebody you you
know you you've crossed paths of course
we work together on tombstone oh my god
of course that's right friends for years
but what a cast god that's right
falcomer's great in that and and um he
was brilliant brilliant star yeah um and
as
[ __ ]
yeah yeah so he played konks in the
original compound that was another tough
one to say with the
come this dead
and you are queefs queefs yes
uh how do you say it exactly enos queen
that's wild enos queen you you seem so
well versed in
obviously you've done so much work
you've experienced so much movie making
great movie making and it seems like you
have a real love for it a real passion
have you thought about making your own i
mean is that something that uh
i'm surprised you you haven't i've
collaborated as a producer with a few
outings with a really
creative house called news productions
and roberta hanley we made
the stuff that we did was always a
little bit punk and left of center i
can't help but you know while i have
this love of mainstream traditional yeah
cinema i i have this punk and post-punk
heart that that likes the lunatic fringe
and
cater to it much to the dismay of my
various representatives yeah you know
through the years yes not the most
probably
no i probably you know i've certainly
you know contributed to the kind of
curious off-ramp a more traditional
career would have taken had i just been
satisfied with letting um others craft
that journey but i'm like no i've got to
make this edward silent film
after
right after titanic well i want to see
that stuff
you know look up um
i woke up early the day i died which was
a uh
a opus by edward jr wow uh a silent film
with an incredible cast what and it was
you know always seemingly hobbled by
some you know
hollywood story our our distributor
died and it was you know there was just
something always nefarious and weird at
the end of at the end of the process
like why did that not why was it shown
for a week and only found in germany on
a bootleg right why was that film the
first film to be completely leaked to
the internet in 2000 it's just i love
that stuff but
has built this cult status that people
seem to love if you can find it wait
wait wait wait wait so it's like it's an
actual silence actually edward jr made
it edward jr wrote it it was his
unproduced opus curiously about a thief
with a sonic disability only ed wood
would write a silent movie about a sonic
visibility how do you show them how do
you show that
by using a lot of stock footage of
course and uh
printing uh the script on the screen we
we
it's really well crafted i have to say
we uh dodie doran edited who
you know
cut memento yes did army of the dead and
she's brilliant oh my god so we worked
together and really crafted something
how cool built off of what arisa
leopolis the director who
found the script from eddie's uh widow
are those specific choices are you
to go from these mains you're in these
big hits and then
they kind of left i've noticed that left
of center choices nothing's more left of
center than ed would um i didn't know
about this one and this was trust me
this was right after titanic i finished
seven months the biggest a-list movie
and i was like i need to scratch this
itch i've got to i've got to rock the
house i've just got to do something for
me what was that was there also a sense
after titanic i i didn't know it did it
really take over a year to film that
we did seven months our portion wow
that was in mexico but they shot that
movie for three years jesus god because
it was so big were you concerned that it
might like pigeonhole you as this arch
you had mentioned like
you know being somebody liking the
archness of some of these characters but
but
might it have pigeonholed you or were
you afraid at the time that it might
universally yeah yeah yeah yeah
it took what was already like oh you're
an interesting bad guy to like you know
to be universal like that's you might as
well have been the iceberg
[Music]
[Music]
hey life is short listeners i want you
to imagine that you're on a warship in
the final days of world war ii you're
excited to go back home looks like the
war is ending you've just delivered the
necessary parts for the atom bomb but
then disaster strikes your ship is
struck by enemy torpedoes and within
minutes you're floating in the ocean
fighting for survival from wondering
against the odds is an immersive podcast
that puts you in the shoes of resilient
people surviving harrowing ordeals in
their new season you'll hear about the
infamous sinking of uss indianapolis and
the survivors fight to stay alive it's a
fascinating story you probably know the
story of the uss indianapolis from the
famous scene in jaws that robert shaw
recounts um it is harrowing to say the
least the sailors who survived the
attack were stranded in the open ocean
for
uh five days i believe they endured
brutal weather
rough seas dehydration salt water
poisoning hallucinations and it was one
of the deadliest shark attacks in
history
against the odds has the harrowing true
story of how the brave men of the
indianapolis survive the worst disaster
at sea in u.s naval history listen to
against the odds on apple podcasts
amazon music or you can listen a week
early and add free by joining wonder
plus in the wondery app hey life assured
listeners business wars is a podcast
from wondering that brings you the full
stories behind some of the biggest
business battles in history in their new
season you'll hear about the fight
between espn versus fox sports to
dominate the sports television industry
espn is the american cable network that
blaze the trail for around the clock
sports coverage athletes even change the
way they play just to get on
sportscenter's nightly highlight reels
but right around the corner rupert
murdoch's fox sports channel started
gaining on espn in the us the sports tv
business is worth more than 12 billion
dollars the question is who will come
out on top fox sports or espn listen to
business wars espn versus fox sports on
apple podcast amazon music or you can
listen one week early and add free by
joining wondering plus in the wondery
app
[Music]
how do you toe the line between playing
somebody obviously bad and uh like you
like you were talking about for mcgruber
you want to play it more realistic how
did you
find the charm in that guy what what was
that like which character in in titanic
i played it like a cop yeah oh
interesting yeah if you watch it yeah
you know because there was fundamentally
something wonderful i don't i mean i
don't mean to trivialize it yeah yeah no
i i found the hubris you know he kind of
carries the age for a bit into the love
trying yeah right the time so does she
and so does he doesn't do it singularly
there is no question in his mind he's
getting off the boat and there's nothing
he can't pretty much solve yeah so it's
an annoyance yeah if anything yeah and
that was absurdly funny that's true to
jim and brought us great pleasure uh-huh
that in that case we would laugh every
time i bet
i that was it wasn't in the comedy it
was in the drama yes just piss ourselves
laughing that makes because you're such
an ass and but so confident yeah like
sinking shrinking where's the chick you
know like i you know it's also like we
all know what's going to happen
you know what's going to happen you know
the tragedy that will befall everybody
so so to commit to that confidence and
that like and also the concern of like
you know such in retrospect trivial
concerns like i'm jealous of this guy or
to have any any other concerns other
than survival in that atmosphere but
that was bigger for him and yeah it was
in there to it was in that that we mine
very real emotion which was
because of the age this is someone who
never could have considered that ruffian
to uh have rated
right yeah you've been a worthy
suitor he had no status
none it was like it's like it was like
chinese to him yeah
possibly so let alone
simultaneously the and it was a
an allegory for the rise of the bohemian
you know
totally and and you the artist
you had this
you know i don't know when level m was
written by puccini but not you know
probably what
around the same
uh period per se
um
you had
this uh cultural
shift in acceptance where you know
the the broker the romance the
romanticism yeah the starving artist
was clashing with it was being
introduced in culture and art and in our
lives yes the idea that security and
station and name and wealth and
all these things could be challenged by
the meager trappings of the every man
and this was also around the rise of the
concept of you know workers rights and
yes and you know so you have
financial dynasties like the vanderbilts
yeah so
there was there was deep waters you know
to dive and so to speak around the
comeuppance around the the realization
that oh my god this rates and even cal i
think was impressed by
by the art he hated destroying that
image because he was good he was good as
well that moment he wants to wrinkle
he's like
[ __ ] you know yeah totally you know well
it's also the it's a great examination
of class and and like you have to do i i
think one of the reasons you're so good
in it is because you
you don't do so little you you never
like hit it too hard it's it's that it's
what you said it's that that type of
entitlement is the most odious when it
is so casual yeah it could have almost
passed as a gentleman that the whimsy
and the light the lightness of that like
uh you know
completely
uh you know
um
the joy yeah of of of the novelty of
that is
yes there's a it's a snobby charm i
guess and and
um it plays on your on your looks and
your ability to be charming and you're
like kind of erudite nature it's it's uh
it's really a wonderful performance but
but but i i've always wondered if you
did have that fear you know i've never
done anything like that no one
titan fear of being typecast of being
like well
now i'm the bad guy that already
happened i mean i was like you know by
that point i just know i was putting a
nail in the coffin come on oh bring it
on here it goes you know
well it reminded me of of uh
the story about bruce dern with john
wayne and true grit i mean had never
died in a movie oh yeah what's the story
yes
and and wayne would say to bruce dern
who who shoots him kills
a man who kills john wayne oh my god
yeah and so what is that experience like
then walking in those shoes post titanic
um
having been this this universally
reviled
person uh
well there was about there was a there
was a counterpoint to that which is also
curiously revered
there's a there's a dynamic of like
better to be feared than uh you know
that there is a weird respect in that
story totally yeah that you know dudes
were like you're a terrible shot you
know kind of had like what's wrong with
her guys were like
championing cal that's you know
that was weird yeah um
you know that's weird there were people
who felt he was
an archetype of their
aspiration or their club heads of state
and captains of industry had some secret
affinity i'm sure
and then there were just simply two
kinds of women which was team cal and
team jack which was you know how could
you do that to that beautiful boy and
the others were you know i like the bad
boy you know yeah
i don't mind a little slap you know
where's that diamond oh my god yeah that
was funny something for everyone but but
but but none of it was about you i mean
that's the interesting thing talking to
you now
yeah i i but it was such an indelible i
i said this to ryan to my theory about
ryan phillippi is that he was in cruel
intentions it was such an indelible
performance and uh that i until i met
him and got to know him work for them i
i always sort of saw him as being
this kind of affluenza type guy you know
a guy who was maybe like a little
pompous or whatever a little like uh
well
come to find out totally working class
loves comedy humble you know uh but i
had i'd projected all of this um
onto him i think because of some of
those performances those early
performances so i it must be an
interesting experience for you to then
have people approach you as though
you were that character as though you
somehow embodied that when in fact you
were
a trained
good actor i don't know that must be
weird as opposed to an [ __ ]
yeah and [ __ ] that james cameron just
captured with you know
yeah which was the case yeah okay all
right well okay
were you always referred to as billy
billy did people when you were growing
up did kids come i was my dad was bill
okay i was billy i'm william george
zane jr if you want to look at my
passport which is a bit haughty
it is a bit hard but it's it's um billy
is a lot more innocent and playful a
name than william you have like a real
sense of like like an intellectual
curiosity that is more befitting of a
william i would think like billy
billy i don't know billy is it it's but
i know you as a billy it's syllable
distribution billy yeah this was a it
sounds like a fake name and it does it
seem it seemed good for media you know
maybe a rockabilly
singer in the 50s no but billy
especially in the 80s 90s billy was like
a cool one billy's a great billy zane is
a great name but it was short it was
anglicized then did your parents
emphasize it from uh zan zanatakis
it was close
which is a greek name my father
shortened it before i was born ah so i
was born zayn zane
my people are spartan and
zombie tacos
and and did your parents continue after
you found success as an actor did they
continue to act as well did you ever act
together
um
no they had
shifted to being educators yeah running
a business in the you know in the late
70s
um and then certainly
enjoyed our outings but
you know my dad did a couple films with
my sister lisa's lisa
right you know done wonderful work oh
tons of stuff yeah and film and tv and
uh from like
er and la
[Music]
which is you know great pop love but she
um
she just did a uh
i can't remember the name of the new
film
lisa i didn't know that was your sister
yeah she's wonderful oh wow really the
talent in the family and a great singer
songwriter and did she was she younger
sister did she did you had you got into
the business already depends who's
asking me okay okay all right no she was
she was she was older but i came here
first then she she was in she was in new
york she was doing stage in chicago wow
and and uh then started doing um
uh
quite a bit of film uh
yeah
when she and
is you know wonderfully talented and
still working and she did a film with my
father didn't film with her oh wow
[Music]
and uh see you guys yeah the folks
continued um
[Music]
certainly being supportive by all means
and uh again they you know my folks are
singing in the rain like 42 times when
they were dating in the theaters right
so oh my god literally in the dna so the
idea that you know kids want to throw on
the grease paint and yuck it up yeah and
they were like go for it
i bet that's how they were it's probably
how you can see i don't want to think
too much about it no i'm
sure
you might have been conceived during
singing in the rain oh my god which
scene yeah
that's the thing could not make him
laugh
well you could only ask um i know and
that's back when you had to see a movie
in the theater uh a
director i worked with told me that he
had seen jaws
i forget like some reaped like 80 70 80
something times and
i said well how's that possible in the
theater he said i would just go every
day i would just go it was playing for
however many months like titanic it was
one of those movies um
so god that what how exciting then to 18
and i'm just now trying to imagine you
on the set of the future
one that would become like rival jaws is
like one of the classics uh
what an experience that must have been
for you
it was um
it was epic and it was because it also
we were capturing the 50s yes and that
to me was cinema yeah i had i had i had
just been watching you know rebel
without a cause kazan
and uh
you know a lot of uh early you know
early brando and dean and the and that
level of technicolor here this film was
that this was cinema
cinema was nostalgic to me cinema was ah
something captured of that period so to
be in that gear around those cars in
that setting
yeah that was
truly an immersive
crazy experience i bet i bet um
now um you know and period is
interesting
you know we're capturing i'm right now
i'm working on a project
um producing to play
curiously uh marlon brando oh my god
in um
[Music]
in his period as an activist really it
focuses it's not about a great cradle to
grave it's just a very near uh
kind of narrow slice uh through the lens
through the eyes of the architect he
hired to build his compound in tahiti
and uh it's
it's a very uh
great challenge and an interesting
um
journey but it again shines the light on
on the little known
fact of his work he did as an activist
for civil rights for indigenous rights
but really about his in his
environmental rights which no one knew
about this is this is
and this was fascinating and that's what
the film's about and again it's a period
piece so it's early 70s just to
get back to making
period cinema so i'm maybe that's why
i'm rocking the turtlenecks in them well
i was going to love you you look
i love that period too and i and i i
discovered it because i was doing a deep
dive on the dick cavett show and doing a
lot we almost had dick kevin on the show
i've been talking to dick's wife and
it's a long boring story but i love i
mean his appearance on the dick cava
show i'm sure he created that that
interview
like
with little feather with sachin
no that was the uh of the oscars how was
the oscars but i i'll send you
a clip of the dick cavett recreation oh
oh you're gonna you can't show it
no no i won't no but i'm gonna we shot
we shot the during covet we were like
one of the first um
covet compliant productions
and and we just we decided to shoot all
of the recreations of godfather and last
tango and what the cabin and
carson and then we had to shut down for
cover because most of the film takes
place in tahiti and that the country you
know we were going to shoot fiji and
then that [ __ ] yeah that opened and
closed and then we went to tahiti
scouted there
and we're in the middle of the
production now we have you know so we
had to wait for it to open and now
waiting for uh
hurricane season or a cyclone season to
end so wait billy
you're actually
oh so you're shooting oh you're actually
shooting it
oh wow that's [ __ ] cool it's neat wow
okay i love that period i had no idea he
was so
god how bright and articulate and
compassionate he was um i think walked
the walk he was so brave actors weren't
doing it yeah no one was no one put
their their ass in the lineup oh no you
know he's the man was filled with
complexities and contradictions and
certainly have tragedy
but
what was curiously consistent was his
empathy
and his commitment yeah to put his money
where his mouth was and and walk the
walk for
some levels of equanimity and yeah
and noble causes um and that oscars
moment was really ahead of its time and
and was a shameful i think
moment in hollywood history you
mentioned john wayne earlier but i
wasn't john wayne one of the
those who were particularly hostile to
sachin oh yeah the backlash even while
the speech was being made it was no one
it would just now it's everyone's out
everyone's sent to a statement he was
the first person and he didn't do it for
self-gratifying yeah he wasn't even
there
no
he the reason he did it was to shine a
light i mean wounded knee was blowing up
yeah and they say that
this there was a ceasefire happened as a
result of the broadcast that wow wow
washington was like told fbi to you know
stand down because of the attention now
put upon it so he literally saved lives
with that of course in hollywood he was
vilified for now just you know receiving
the nod creatively but he wisely used
the platform live to kind of go hey this
is a lot of unfair treatment and we can
do better yeah and obviously an issue
that is still um in need of of
adjustment and really like a hard look
today it's it's it's never really been
properly addressed and
i think what the the crimes we've
committed uh have never really been
properly addressed so hopefully that
movie you're doing will will help
reignite some discussion about that and
also just shine a light on the fact that
this you know he was the first person to
um
[Music]
you know try to marshal
nasa grade science and and the bleeding
edge of innovation towards
zero carbon footprint wow in like the
late 60s wow trying to figure out how to
build sustainably yeah no one was like
no one was having this conversation
looking at you now you you
look so much like bran it never occurred
to me how much you look like brando you
it it makes such perfect sense just from
a purely aesthetic point of view and and
from an acting point of view had you did
you ever do and not to reduce your
performance to an impression but was he
an impression of yours that that was in
your like arsenal
no
because he was in so many others you
know i mean it wasn't something and the
only way to approach him was by not
doing an impression yeah yeah you had to
you had to approach him the way he
approached work which was
very
loose yeah and a little bit he was
playful right allow things to happen to
you yeah yeah i mean i've i've worked
that way for years and it's been it's
it's been
it's
bore fruit you know which is just simply
don't don't front load it don't don't
make things happen uh-huh yeah let him
let him
you know let him happen to you and react
to it but look for those beautiful
accidents and find the things that might
you know pick up the cat that was
crossing set and use it in the scene
because now you've got something
grounded to play with that you didn't
know you'd find you know do like look
for those those things that will keep it
fresh he was definitely certainly
his last few performances known for that
like really
you know
being present to that kind of stuff
there were great stories about dr moreau
when he was doing island of dr morrow
where he wanted
there was a little person that was an
extra background actor and he thought he
was so charmed by this person that he
just wanted him around all the time
so he he would just incorporate him into
the scenes i i love the idea of being
present to
anything he seemed like he really um
i mean worked that way and what a fun
thing for you to get to do while you're
playing absolutely how cool i mean he
had done that level of invention and
even in on the waterfront the famous
scene of defense where he picks up you
know her glove
and he starts putting it she dropped it
he picked it up while they're talking he
didn't just ignore it oh a prop dropped
i'll pretend it didn't happen no we're
living this we're doing this i'm gonna
pick it up and while we're talking i'm
gonna try to put it on and that just
became that was just behavior that was
found so
he was probably the you know among the
first to just
be
on film
life could be a dream sweetheart
hello hello again you're booming over
we'll meet again
[Music]
we have a quick lightning round question
billy if you'll uh indulge our lightning
round section
um
really quick what is your favorite emoji
cowboy smiling cowboy oh okay yeah i use
it
i bet yeah you have a cowboy spirit i
have a cowboy hat
yeah that's what i i wear it a lot
it's self-referential it is it's like
that's me hey how's it going
i
uh who was your first celebrity crush i
imagine you were the first of many for
many people ursula andrews
oh sure yeah tina louise
yeah ginger from gilligan's yep yep sure
um
and then uh you know crushed hard on
nostalgia kinski
oh yeah oh yeah like the cat people cat
people oh yeah yeah yeah um
what is your favorite ice cream flavor i
like rocky road okay it's cool yeah cool
little marshmallows some chocolate nuts
nuts what is your uh what is your
favorite holiday i like thanksgiving do
you do a big thing do you do big zayn it
depends it's always different
it's never it's really been consistent
um but
i like the periphery i like the color of
the sky
and the turning of the leaves and the
the the
you know the bite in the air and the
shift in the wardrobe
it's you know you're not in dead winter
if there's just there's your kids don't
get that now i mean like we had that
growing you know we have seasons in l.a
we have you know we absolutely do yeah
they're not quite as market marked as
oh nice
lucky them they'll get to experience the
bone chilling
they want to build a snowman oh that's
cool um
what is your what is oh well are you a
sports fan did you grow up watching
sports into sports i had chicago teams
so i yeah i was i was in high school
during all the three beats four pete's
soon after
oh so i was watching jordan no no the
heyday and the bears you know oh yeah
you know the cubs were always an
interesting you know i get we finally
got uh
to watch that happen as an adult
in the recent history but oh man you
know
i saw the most heartbreaking walter
payton
documentary the other day oh what an
amazing play i loved watching peyton
play yeah me too
i saw a lot of those airborne
touchdowns
live you know freezing oh really
how cool that was amazing oh how great
but yeah and then and then yeah you
would you had you're right you that was
a heyday because then
the bulls yeah
late 80s they they started
their run how lucky um
if you could be an athlete what what
sport would you play if you could play a
professional sport
i played
soccer or
uh people uh in high school and i did
enjoy that very much um i
love swimming
oh yeah um you can see that but not in
not i mean can be a team sport to a
degree yeah but yeah quite an individual
dynamic um
[Music]
and uh i love frisbee
oh really that ultimate would be uh you
know should be in the x games but maybe
it is
you're good at it i like this
yeah well that was close
um
what what is an acclaimed movie that
you're embarrassed to say that you
haven't seen like that maybe people
shame you for what you haven't seen blah
does it have to be a movie no
uh
breaking bad
oh okay yes
i know it's i know it's great i'm sure i
know it's great but it's a commitment
game of thrones especially they're all
commitments i know you know
i'm a like what what any free time
whatever the hell that is is you know
i'm a parent you got a yeah yeah yeah
and a painter um
what is it sometimes combined
what is a um what is a game show that
you would love to be a contestant on
past or present make me laugh bobby
oh yeah comedians would go out and try
to make people laugh a record amount of
time
and watching people hold just just
you know contort in agony
uh and not laugh was
just yes fabulous guilty pleasure good
youtube
i've seen there's it's it um have you
seen silent library you would love that
no japanese there's a japanese game show
oh
youtube that billy you like what i've
seen
well well it was a big hit on when like
youtube just started like in the early
2000s
it's it's hilarious but it's similar
premise where they have to be quiet in a
library and they all try to make each
other laugh really gross
there's nothing funnier than that i know
i know uh and in practical jokers you
would love class library in churches
it's like yeah
exactly the stakes are so high your
kneecaps blow off that that contained
pressure is just it's exactly
it's such a joy um uh do you drink
coffee or tea and if so how do you take
it
uh both i like a uh
um
i'm i'm a fan of black coffee and joe
just straight yep
black coffee uh i like a cappuccino
amaretto
oh yeah you know you want to warm it up
and
and uh
you want to add a little something fun
to it and you're not driving i like a um
[Music]
i like a proper macchiato
a little wet a little bit of foam on top
but not a mini cappuccino which tends to
be made uh
posing as a
uh wow
that's a proper italian
tea
i like um there's something called
mountain tea from greece from mount
piagatos which is the
mountain in sparta and it's like
it's kind of in the chamomile range but
not really it's a it's a it's dried
thick
flour you can get them at greek markets
look up mountain tea it's incredibly
medicinal mountain tastings and we'll
keep you
alive and strong oh wow uh i want to
drink and eat whatever you're you're
ingesting um t
uh i might go to thessaloniki i was
there a couple months ago billy i had
where i was in an art fair there i had a
show no [ __ ]
just yeah it's amazing like a year ago
oh no kidding
i went this past summer and um
god just loved it my my girlfriend might
be going back to work there so i'm like
i hope you do i hope you take
whatever the job is because selfishly i
want to i want to go back
at that t if you're you know i will
if you're that close you should also uh
check out um
[Music]
mount olympus
i don't know it's not it's not that far
and uh you can hike up or drive up and
then hike and it's quite amazing i will
um what do you hike do you do that stuff
in la do you live in a hiking area
um not far yeah yeah i do i i do enjoy
it i um
it's nice i mean i grew up in chicago
which is flat as attack beautiful um you
know uh riviera like town yeah on the
lake yeah the idea of like irregular
topography was something that was
mind-blowing i you know when i first
came to l.a i just hunched back to being
a kid
remembering all the commercials for toys
that would be like action toys yes you
know i remember guys running like big
gym and trucks over like yes yes i was
like totally yeah
i grew up in the city and i'm like i
don't understand i was finding all this
yeah and i was like
like what you know about foot elevation
was like
mind blowing
i know well i i remember billy coming to
l.a experiencing those um
where i'd seen e.t you know the settings
for like e.t and and poltergeist right
it was like pasadena mountains i
remember thinking like communities yes
those like kind of desert mountain
communities um that always seemed so
like movieish to me and and now of
course i i
see them all the time and i still think
that isn't that funny that like
i you never outgrow certain things like
i still think oh this is this is from a
movie this is um
uh if you could learn another language
what would it be
english
yeah
yeah but you really master it you really
want to really have to
i you know
i would love to
legitimately learn french i you know
yeah i know enough of the romance
languages to get by with
romance and ordering a
cappuccino
you know yeah uh i enough to get by with
waiters
that's cool
because
yeah
or both
what is your favorite cereal
um
life
yes [ __ ] life is great i love life
how about cinnamon life
gilding the lily okay
okay that's fair
that's fair
well said that's really
what about cinnamon toast crunch because
they're in the same face i'll give you
that okay okay
uh if you had to choose a different
first name what would it be
nathan
okay okay
nathan zane
is that why you did that
is that because is that a nathan lane
joke
and okay you just stumbled into it i
just always thought it's all about
syllable distribution you need a two
syllable front or a single syllable back
and nathan like nathan hale or nathan
nathan from
from uh
dolls nathan detroit well funny enough
billy uh nathan who was on this show
told me that that's how he came up with
that name nathan
you know
the first two that were shot down by
their mother was uh you know hendrix
which i thought was an interesting first
name because it sounded very english
while being rock and roll yeah yeah and
i wanted to name my my daughter
professor
oh which i thought you know in school
you'd always have to be referred to as
professor zane that much to the chagrin
of her teachers no no no no no i that's
i love it i had an idea to name my kid
doctor for the same reason
yes doctor long doctor
oh that's so great so you were serious
so your wife was like
that's seriousness
well cause i'm always interested in like
naming how do you how do you settle like
naming pets for me has been hard enough
but like to to give a kid a person a
name like that's always been
such an interesting experience
that i've never gone through but i would
imagine i'm always so curious about that
so what how did you settle on the names
who who picked the names
uh we did collectively yeah um more
traditional name
um
traditional and uh
informed by classic cinema
oh cool i'm sure they're out there in
the zeitgeist but i don't feel like yeah
no no no no no no don't do that but but
now i'm of course i'm curious because i
can't know um if you had a now i want to
know you will it's not hard
that's smart uh if you had a sandwich
named after you i mean like uh sandwich
oh you too oh so what's up
i was kidding but then i realized i'm
not kidding um
there's a there is a uh
a hot dog
in um chicago
uh-huh um which is known for their
you know vienna beef for some reason
vietnamese yeah in chicago yeah uh if
across from depaul university
um
that asked to name a dog
after me
and what i would want on it oh great and
um i i remembered a uh
but what came to mind was the absurd
dubbed overdub dialogue from woody
allen's what's up tiger lily oh yes yeah
which was there's a fight scene between
two people in a hotel room and the
insults are flying like you know
you know uh spartan dog you know turkish
you know they were just going through so
spartan dog was something that just
always stuck in my mind and and i
thought
yeah i'm spartan i was like okay we'll
do a spartan dog what's a spartan dog i
said mustard on you know it's like
because everything had thousands of
toppings yes everyone had i was like no
no just mustard very spartan
i didn't know that's where the term
spartan came from
um
i don't know if it came from
there what do you oh the original what
was smarter
yeah yeah but
it comes farther but the idea like the
the uh the use of the word meaning
meaning
minimal
yeah
was yeah philosophically was you know
and then extended into the like the
stoics ethos of the of the yeah
aesthetics
um wow interesting so it's just it's
just mustard wow
that's i love that a spartan dog uh what
is your favorite tom hanks movie splash
yes yes mr mango
uh yeah yes john candy um oh what a
brilliant well these are quick would you
rather take uh
and appropriate a time machine to the
past or the future
how long um let's say you get a solid
week you to explore and you're safe
it presupposes that you're safe
uh
i think the past yeah where would you go
is there a specific era you'd like to
visit hill valley home town square no uh
yeah 1955 1955 1955 1955 oh that's so
good uh you're about
um
what the hell is a gigawatt
that's the best
do people yell that to you do people
yell things to you iceberg straight out
do they just yell things
uh yeah i'll get i'll get a lot of
zoolander references oh yeah
complimentary and kind of cool
they say your whole name like zoolander
does all the time yeah for some reason
people are like i cannot not say both of
your names just like
you know
what literally is he put a cork in it
zayn or it's like uh yeah he said you're
cool dude or whatever yeah put a coin
it's very funny
thank you
yeah yeah funny
um yeah and when i don't know
yeah um
so i mean jesus throw a rock
yeah well now you'd fit right in with
that that 60s 70s uh
just with your
then you'd pick an event if you go back
and like what do you want to see would
you like something would you be watching
are you trying to like you know change
the course of history are you just
trying to be a fly in the wall
[Music]
what are we doing here no i don't i mean
i wouldn't i don't think i'm that i
don't know i don't know i don't want to
level i just want to
oh i don't want to meddle in anything i
want to
get on the tram and go exactly exactly
um are you a are you more of a talker a
texter when you communicate with people
um
both i i i yeah love the sound of my own
thumbs
yeah
it's kind of
i i overwrite yeah i need to reduce i
write wrong i write i love long messages
i love so do i feel like
as
yeah
yeah perfect for the podcast the
never-ending story of uh you know i'm
sorry i know we're at two hours and i'm
the same uh tonight we're almost a night
or morning person
morning
although i'm up i i both i i i i there's
no room
you don't sleep
yeah
how much do you need i'll go to
apparently not much uh yeah
five to six but i i do well with more
but i have crazy i don't know if it's
adrenaline or ability to really marshall
what i i'm just used to
like i can do a late i love i love the
solitude of late night and the clarity
of that time
and i really enjoy the creative space i
think it's just lower density in the
airwaves and traffic
but i love early mornings and i get up
early to get my kids ready and make you
know i like a slow start before school
not panic crazy so i
try to ease them into
into the morning if i can wake them
laughing that would be great because it
sets the day so that requires you know
staging the lighting rides the music
choices some of the things and then you
know while we all love cereal i try to
give them a more you know anything that
would require napkin rings well yeah
what is what is your uh routine i mean
what do what do you consume uh what's
your secret because you really do look
incredibly youthful
and and you seem to have energy of a
youthful person thank you
um i've been i
i've been doing
you know
everything in moderation but i can't say
everything but i think yeah you know i
listen to my body i try to you know i i
i've been i enjoy macrobiotic cooking i
love cooking
that's really awesome but i just threw
down you know some greek lamb chops i
brought to my friends and we tore those
down like lollipops yesterday at you
know the art studio and a little optical
shop in front of it and
so you know if i want to eat meat i'll
eat meat if i
from blanching red cabbage to eat with
my
sesame rice another that you know yeah
you just gotta
yeah change it up and i've been going to
pilates like every day for the last like
three weeks i'm kind of
addicted to that oh no kidding that's
amazing that's just like
i love yoga but i think pilates me too
it's just what turned you on to pilates
i did i had done it a while ago and it's
after i dropped my daughter off at
school there was just a studio nearby
huh and i wanted to try it and i just
i'm the only dude in there it's me and a
bunch of you know
yeah women doing their thing and i'm
like i don't know why more men aren't
doing this thing
i think i grew another inch back and uh
you know in your body yeah your body you
have back issues those are gone oh great
it's just it's very leaning and uh
i do it you know early morning like
about 8 a.m
oh i'm gonna check well okay but that's
fun so that's a routine and food wise
you you change it up skin i use my
friend's product called cos
organic
okay
and it's all natural no
no chemicals whatsoever cosmo organic
chaos
cause organic skin care wow
instagram it's pretty it's no it i will
happily not just because she wants me to
join her in the company
because she you know i really believe
she she's eleni simmons is her name she
was a is a model and a mom and a single
mom now and had built this
you know product because she was a
supermodel and having worked so much
yeah yeah right she broke out so she
just had to wear
to build to actually create a skincare
line that has absolutely no chemicals in
it not even stabilizers not even water
like you buy you look at products that
say oh they're all natural and organic
you there's words you can't
pronounce because there's always
something in it this product zip and she
uses like manuka honey and
and tomato oil and of a cut like this
concert of natural products that just
are like skin food it's just
amazing it's a meal so i don't i'm not
just plugging for the sake of getting a
friend's brand yeah it works i'm 55 and
i'm lucky
it's amazing billy and by the way we
don't mind plugging just for the sake of
plugging either but it sounds like it
came from a more um definitely more
organic check it out you'll love it
they'll ship out you know whatever the
facial form
uh beecher mountains do you prefer
uh what water
uh yeah that's a good point well in
greece you get both right yeah you do i
i i which you know goes to my answer
which is like do i have to choose
yeah yeah i i do love both um yeah
i
i love the water
um and i do love a beach but i've i've
grown to really love the
you know the residence of the mountains
yeah yeah yeah especially california i
always forget how beautiful those
mountains are um i don't know if you
have a strong opinion about this toilet
roll over or under
by um
[Music]
uh
under if you under yes you don't get
this the the the spill and roll when you
tear over you're going to lose a lot i
think under that grip against the roll
and not
waste i'm really breaking this down for
you but i was trying to yeah no i
appreciate it over you're pulling
and the thing and you end up wasting
people oh see under i sometimes have a
hard time finding
where it is over is easier for me in
that sense but that you make a good case
now this less one is less wasteful
finish this sentence if you will no i
want to end on toilet paper this is it
this hold the plug i'm done
please get me out of this
logical
wrap-up
well you can still use this as a
scanological opportunity good
finish finish this sentence if you will
billy life is short so
sow seeds i think just keep it at that
let's explore that statement and respect
those seeds it was the first thing life
is short so so
yes or
a period and a new sentence that you
should
so sew your seats biological imperative
i would say
yeah yeah um it's it's our yeah it's our
life calling so well
i have
so
enjoyed this
i truly have this is
i've always been such a fan of yours and
so i'm glad i got to uh what a pleasure
to meet you this way jess
likewise and i i hope to work with you
and see out in the world that would be a
great pleasure thanks val i'll see you
out there in the world i look forward
all right likewise thank you truly
[Music]
so
that just happened
yes there's um
there's a kind of a
it's hard to get past
yeah there's an old-fashioned there's a
rat packy vibe
yes there's an old like a whiskey soaked
uh
kind of nightclub charm
yes you know kind of a and he's got this
there's also an erudite sound that he
has he's so perfect i mean maybe i'm
just seeing him in titanic now but he
really it's such great casting and he
really is um
he he has this charming but like kind of
wealth there's like there's like
upper class yes charm to him there's he
kind of has the most interesting man in
the world vibes
yeah he's you know a world traveler and
he's very bright and articulate and he's
yes and he's interested in so many
different things and i feel like he's
been a man of the he's been just enjoyed
the
nice things in the world he's sexy
you were dancing around and you just
wanted a gym yeah he's sexy
don't you think he's sexy there's a
there's a confidence he has and he's got
a sexy boy he's got it and obviously
he's very good looking yes uh i guess i
think he's very sexy yeah i guess
he is in a very uniquely and maybe i'm
just
imagining what he was wearing but in a
uniquely like 70s in in like that time
period he had a turtleneck on he had a
turtleneck and a leather jacket so it
was um
it was like one of those cop shows like
like french connections he was like i've
never seen french connection oh man
she's speaking of sexy that's gene
hackman
that's real 70s anti-hero
vibe gene hackman stayed sexy throughout
his career i would say i think so don't
you think he's one of those guys that
aged really well i'm like sean connery
someone like that aged really well in
fact you know was i talking to you
recently where i was trying to come up
with somebody a comparison
uh
about sexiness and we were talking about
like what is like what does it take to
be sexy and and and i just kept coming
up with like
i think i said like harrison you know
and you were like well like what do you
mean and i was like well like uh
gene hackman or harrison ford i might
not have been you but i was like that he
was one of my examples for what a sexy
guy is
gene hackman was eugene hackman and
harrison ford and he remains
a good example to you yeah i think so
but i don't know if people would agree
with that harrison ford i would have
agreed with until now
the earring phase yeah the earring
really and and the overly curmudgeonly i
know
that's not sexy it's a little like hair
yeah
it's a bit too cranky at this point like
porch guy yeah yelling at kids
i know i know the earring kind of
because you know we talked about this
before it's like what's sexy is like the
not trying of course he says well billy
zane also i think
it's it makes sense that he was weaned
on those like carrie grant those older
movies totally you know uh john wayne
movies and carrie grant he had like he's
got a he's got a
kind of a nostalgic vibe yes you know
carrying a throwback he's a throwback he
is he really a sexy throwback
all right christian we get it you think
he's sexy
he is a sexy
that'd be a good name for his
autobiography yeah
yeah by the way he's gonna be perfect
for that marlon brando part he looks so
much once he said that and once you said
it you're like wow you know i never
realized that's how much like him
i started thinking about that he looks
so much like totally and and especially
now because he's a little bit i mean
he's in great shape and all that
wasn't that funny the pilates
and you know there's some ladies there
yes
and you made a
uh boner joke that he didn't i did yeah
he goes i i'm one inch longer now and
you go oh your body
oh my god that's wild yeah that's right
you made another penis joke too at one
point
when he was talking about liking frisbee
uh-huh he goes yes i'm really um i'm
really into discs
and you said oh that was close that's
right i remember that one
i'm really into discs
discs
okay
uh
yeah he is um but he also i understand
like
why he's been used in those comedies
because there's there's a seriousness to
him too
that is when it's applied in the right
ways like can be really funny like like
it is in zoolander or it's hard to
explain that i know you were trying to
but i know it's hard to explain it
without dancing around something that
sounds insulting insulting i know
potentially insulting you're like you
don't do this you don't wink at the
camera but yes there's a certain i don't
know like charm and it's fun yeah
but i don't know if he's going for that
i just think that's yeah that's been you
that's why i say he's been used in
certain ways like
i know but but still you know we're
talking about him now is like
having
what a career like what uh i know
and also i love that he doesn't take
himself i mean he is very serious in
these movies and he like commits he's a
good actor
but i like that he doesn't um
he doesn't seem to take himself all that
seriously case in point after he did
titanic he talked about doing that
edward's son i know that movie i didn't
know that i looked it up and it's it
sounds
like something we should watch
i mean i read some of the reviews
yeah it's like what's it about i'm not
sure but it's it looks like the campiest
of all oh yeah movies and it was right
after he did titanic you know and
obviously
like he said his agents his
representatives were oh my god i bet he
could have gotten any bad guy yeah yeah
but i like that he kind of
marches by the beat of his own drum
chris mcglovery
but i he's also i like what he said
about titanic that he played it like it
makes sense that he played it
he understood the comedy in it you know
yeah he played it like a comedy
um and and it does kind of make sense
and it kind of requires that i think
that like his charm and
uh i think that's what made that
character really yeah work totally he
was the perfect villain i mean he was
perfect casting but but such a perfect
performance yeah i know
in order to root for those two as much
as you
did had to to you know to love that
movie as much as people did
you had to
find him
as despicable as
you know those others were charming but
it's a it's a delicate thing because you
also he also has to have enough charm
and a love enough charisma to buy that
kate winslet would have been with him in
the first place that's always been the
like tricky part of that i guess so but
that was also a generational thing in
that era you know yeah like that's true
women didn't have the same kind of
choices often in that like high society
you know you're just kind of like
i don't know you was kind of like chosen
oh man can you imagine like being like a
rich guy and like
and somebody's just like
has to be with you oh it must be
i'm not
poor poor billy zane's character in that
movie no but like what a terrible
feeling what a like terrible thing to
those arranged still going on
in the world counterpoint apparently
arranged marriages work out more i've
yeah have like better uh success rates
well what does it mean to be successful
you stay together yeah yeah that's true
you can't really you can't really
quantify
marital happiness right especially like
in a more
um
you know restrictive culture
where you don't much have much of a
choice to leave well well we digress yes
we sure do back to billy mansplaining
uh arranged marriages uh i agree that um
billy zane
he more he has the intellectual as you
said the intellectual curiosity of a
william
more than a billy yes um you know both
everything that billy's saying
i used to think that about also he's
like a bit like a man like there's
something very kind of like
manly about him you know yeah and billy
is cutesy billy is like hey billy
hey billy billy come get your dinner
right away he knew it he's like nathan
yeah
that question is actually um i was
dubious about that inclusion of that
question aren't you happy now you said
that the other day and i just it's led
to some funny moments yes the nathan one
is great amy man one was funny yes wait
she said dwight oh yeah dwight and
nathan is great he's yes he is then i
was started thinking of of him in
relation to nathan lane
oh my god and and that's a reality show
they seem really different but there is
they have a similar actor and and i
don't just mean that they're actors but
there's a similar kind of uh
old-school actor thing they both have
you know yes i can see them actually
like really get on getting along and
like connecting
do you know what i mean maybe you should
set them up as friends
they're both friends of the show now
that's true
billy nathan nathan billy i wanted his
name to be nathan and nathan wanted his
name maybe to be billy i loved his
elaborate coffee answer
it is so perfect for billy zayn yeah
he's like well i like
good amaretto macchiato
with a touch of foam yeah i know
a slow drip venetian but see that's like
most interesting man in the world [ __ ]
yes yeah that he's
he's cultivated his taste i know
this like
very fancy taste he's like well there's
a place on the island of java that if
you go there at the right before sundown
you're gonna get a
i mean that's like kind of that's
something else that reminds me of brando
you know the eccentricity and the
like attention to detail he he was such
a man of the world and he had such
gravitases
no i know and you got to see those
interviews
i'm talking to everyone too dick cavett
his interview on dick cat it's just
i think i've seen that oh there's some
great ones
look at martin yeah marlon brando
interviews on youtube are really a
really good deep dive to do deep dive
but i'm excited for to watch william
zane do that william zane
i know he
hasn't seen breaking bad he said he
doesn't have time for it but if he's
listening
i would
highly recommend that he uh watch
breaking bad yeah isn't that exciting to
oh my god yeah but he i also just does
william zane have the time yeah
you make time for breaking bad that's
true
that's true he is it is that good it is
really good yeah it's worth the
commitment yeah i mean don't neglect
your children
how old are his kids again i don't know
i don't know if you asked them i don't
know i think they're younger i think
they are because he makes them breakfast
they're not they're probably not like
28. i hope
yeah
uh it's such a good call on his part
about cinnamon life i think i know and
it's the perfect i know you it was like
the perfect
usage of gilding the lily yes i know
you're right guilty i'd lie no
killing the lily yeah yes he's right
he's right i know that's how i feel
about like um
cinnamon toast crunch churro flavor you
know it's like if you have something
right
or extra the cinnamon toast crunch extra
cinnamon extra cinnamon
it is an o
it's cinnamon it's not pronounced
cinnamon no cinnamon but it should be
cinnamon
okay
[Laughter]
should we read a letter sure
yeah
here's a letter you didn't hear the
crinkle because i have it on my phone
uh subject green skittles continued oh
boy isn't it controversial
hi justin and christian i just finished
the allen coming episode and i wanted to
let you know that in canada the lime
skittle is back wow wow you know i was
just there i should have picked some up
yet another reason to like canada oh
yeah yeah that would have been a good
christmas present for you
a trip to canada no no
some lime skittles
okay back to
this i was actually eating skittles
while listening to the episode whoa
so i checked the back of the pack and we
have lime
i took a picture so you could see it
it's funny
i guess she's attached a picture no i
can't see it i believe her
anyway i agree with christian that the
green apple flavor didn't belong and i'm
happy we have lime back so
next time you're up in canada stock up
on your skittles i will
i'm currently pregnant
oh wow
now i'm talking like tom green i'm
currently pregnant baby due around
christmas so for the would you rather i
wanted to ask a somewhat related
question the canadian listeners are
all collectively rolling their eyes as
you do this accent by the way but
they're being nice about it yes they
know that i enjoy the actualized people
yes yes
would you rather go into the past and
meet your ancestors or go into the
future and meet your great great
grandchildren hey oh it's very
appropriate it's like would you back to
future two or three yes oh my god um
what a great question and one we've been
asking people yes pastor future um
this is a good one i
i think selfishly
i would rather
meet a go back and meet my aunties
me too
i'm too scared of what uh my great great
great grandchildren they're like going
to be microchipped and i mean who knows
what people are what happens to our kids
that what's the matter with our kids or
what do they become [ __ ] yeah it's
not just not because i think that
they'll be [ __ ] but it's more the
what the world is going to look like i
know and how they're going to have to
cope great great grant because great
great grandchildren that would mean what
probably like over 100 years from now
i but then at the same time i can
imagine visiting
like my great great great grandfather
and him being and being like hello
and not and and i could see myself being
disappointed you know
yeah he's like are you going to help me
rob this bank it's like oh [ __ ] he said
don't worry just a bunch of poor people
use it yeah what if it's what if it's a
situation like that really awful not to
suggest that our ancestors were a bunch
of boring [ __ ] no but here's the
thing
we don't we don't know i know but i
would i am curious to know what aspects
of their
like how it would um how i might get to
know myself better i mean this is where
the air the self-centered part comes
into play i would want to know through
my ancestors myself a little bit better
and it would just be interesting to see
their behavior and how similar i am or
dissimilar i just i just think going
back is is
you have there's less chance of
something really horrifying i know
happening i know it's it's less there's
less there'd be less anxiety oh unless
the stakes would be lower because worst
case scenario if you go in the past you
meet your relative and they're like not
nice to you or they're or they're jerks
or something right but if you go in the
future and you see that your
great-great-grandchildren are all like
cyborgs yeah then
it would be time to go back to life you
know it's funny i was talking to i think
it was kal penn um
somebody somebody who was not white
recently about this and they were like
uh yeah white people
it's pretty
you know it's easier it's an easier
answer
whereas like you know if you are of a
different ethnicity in this i mean
unfortunately
i i would imagine you'd want to go
sure
great great but i'm also in this
hypothetical i think it's more like
you're safe yeah you're visiting a
relative you're not existing in that
time period right it's more just seeing
your relatives so you don't have to like
survive right
yeah that's true
in that case then obviously you go to
the future because i wouldn't like i'm
picturing um back to future three
yeah and having to be you know chased by
i know bad guys and you know
i'd be terrible i would do in the wild i
would do horribly in the wild west well
because there wouldn't be enough there
wouldn't be enough people to protect you
but i'm a pretty accurate shot i think i
might be a good um you'd have to get
used to i think i'd be good at what do
you call those things uh shooting guns
yeah but when you go back-to-back uh oh
duels duels i think i'd be a good
duelist i would say i just wouldn't
trust the person wouldn't turn around
how do you not tr how do you
i don't know i i
i would do i would like duck i'd sh i'd
duck and then shoot
that's really funny
um there's that
for the woody allen movie we can't tell
you sure we can all right uh it's called
love and death oh he's a really funny
dual scene in that where he shoots
first he gets like a little grazed and
he's like and it's his turn to shoot and
he's like yeah i don't want to shoot you
know
let's just call it a draw
and they're like those are the rules um
okay
aren't you glad i brought that up yes
okay uh back to katie
and her name is katie oh back to the
letter we don't know that yet and i just
looked ahead
sorry love the pod you two are so
genuine thanks i love that compliment so
genuine yeah isn't it isn't that fun we
were talking about that the other week
where it's like it's kind of funny when
people
use that as a real yeah real yeah yeah
but i think genuine is different i i do
too because not everyone is genuine
everyone's real
that's i try i aspire to be genuine i
mean like what if i think we're fairly
genuine i'm sure there are moments from
not where you want to say something but
you feel like you can't for sure yeah
yeah i feel like that's the only time
you're not genuine yeah
yeah for the most part
okay well all right back to uh the
letter it's katie from katie she says
where's she from
vancouver vancouver british columbia
cool you know i've never been to
vancouver oh you would like it it's a
great i'm sure great chinese food right
that's what i think of when i yeah great
well toronto is great chinese food too
right yes i think i was just talking to
somebody about this uh who i worked with
andrea shout out um
uh she's from vancouver we were working
in toronto and uh that's what i said i
said well what's she
seemed to think she made it sound like
vancouver was
way
better oh in terms of
chinese i love the dumplings there's a
plate there's a bunch of places like
spadina and assington there's some great
dumpling places that i've been to in
toronto but i i just have i guess i
haven't spent enough time in vancouver
she she made it sound like oh no no no
like well if you think about it like
there's just a lot more
uh immigrants from that part of the
world that make sense well i'll have to
go eat some chinese food and then for
dessert have some old school skittles
lime skittles so thanks for that now
it's good to know that they're back it's
really good to know it it warms my heart
yeah as you know i'm i like the apple
skittles but i don't want to get into
this yeah also as you know your palette
isn't as refined as mine so um what do
you think billy zane would say to that
both of you are billy zayn has a
much more advanced pal than both of us
put together he would be rolling his
eyes and talking about skittles
childish candy i'm sure he's turned if
he was listening i'm sure he's turned it
off by now he probably makes his own
candy yeah like taffy
um anyway billy thank you if you are
still listening
is it strange calling him billy because
he is such a you're right it really
doesn't suit him the way william would
no it doesn't but again i like that he
goes by that so uh mr william zane thank
you yes and for yes i was sorry i was
interrupting and for what well i was
going to say you skipped over the letter
thanking katie and
and
and saying what the email address is for
others oh yes if you want to write like
katie did um also good would you rather
uh if you want to write in
uh life is short at wondery.com yes and
you don't have to be from canada but we
always appreciate hearing from canadians
we sure do um
and again yeah i'm sorry for the this
slip into that accent that i did but uh
you know
um
and sorry i interrupted your thinking of
billy zane oh yes well it was just that
okay that's billy you know i keep
thinking uh billy baldwin now i i'm now
getting those confused and speaking of
uh iconic and erotic movies and yes and
everyone check out some of uh billy's
work including
mcgruber yeah which you will
likely not regret watching if you i
would say this like that's a that's one
of those shows that's a real litmus test
for just personally uh for for like the
potential to get along with somebody if
i knew that somebody like absolutely
didn't like magruber i'm pretty certain
i wouldn't be able to be i wouldn't get
get along with them interesting that's a
litmus test it is i think so
um anyway
but but i don't want to shame anyone
dude might not like it
uh thank you all for listening and uh
thank you to christian
oh this is the peter out oh
this is about 2021 peter out yeah
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
life is short is hosted by me
chesty long and it's co-hosted by and
produced by you christy christianlong
and also produced by megan v monaco and
katie thief alan senior producer is
michelle miesh lans audio engineer is
sergio enriquez executive producer is
the top dog oh yeah ruff ruff marshall
louie so thanks wandery and thanks to
all of you for listening bye
[Music]
before louie anderson was a guest on our
show i probably had a very similar
relationship to him as many of you did i
knew him from
uh the way he looked or the way he
sounded that very unique voice
familiar touchstones like the things
he'd been on or posted
but i was not at all prepared for
um what a kind person
he he was it struck me right away as
soon as we started the zoom call i
remember he had a um a painting kind of
a crude painting
of his character from baskets uh that
that he'd framed on the wall behind him
and my instinct was because i knew he
was a comedian i was sort of prepared to
be a little bit
snarkier and sarcastic and
maybe kind of spar with him on that
level
the way i've been accustomed to behaving
with with comedians and um
so i started that and uh
and
he immediately disarmed me by
talking about how much he loved the
painting and how grateful he was to the
fan who'd painted it
and
there was no hint of sarcasm or it was
just it was
absolute sincerity and
um
and throughout the rest of our talk
there were similar moments like that
where he
he wouldn't take any sarcastic or snarky
bait he
um was just so kind about uh
people and his experiences and um even
ones that were
kind of negative uh he had such a
compassionate outlook and
he
talked to me about um my grandmother who
uh
christian and i had recently lost and he
did so with such compassion and
sincerity i'll never forget it
um we talked a lot about death and and
life and i'm so grateful that i had that
opportunity because
he really was
such a sweet kind and obviously
hilarious person
um
and so uh in louie's spirit um and in
his honor uh
i i'm gonna try to
find more moments of kindness like that
in my life i'm gonna try to find more
opportunities to be kind uh
because he really seemed to go out of
his way to to behave that way and um
i just want to say to his family and
everyone who knew him um
how grateful i was to have had that
chance and uh we're really gonna miss
him
you